good to see you leave welcome back yeah
hello reject nation i'm greg alba do you
guys remember lisa mihalick it's been
well over a year since she's been here
she is back in Greg's life ready to
destroy it from the inside out whatever
it means I'm here to attack thank you
thank you I'm glad you're doing your job
lisa is farting right now eyes don't
fart that's the cliche don't forget that
guys guys
yeah it's a gender male I've never heard
of that it's the chair people yeah well
Lisa actually has a YouTube channel now
she's happy for over a month right now
so you guys could check out the Lisa
mihalick channel where she does random
zaniness he's not a category it's not
now if there's one type of personality I
feel like Lisa has it's kind of Disney
Princesses she transitioned seven Disney
characters you didn't know we're modeled
on real oh my god what a great
[Laughter]
louder now how can the late thirties
Disney pioneered motion capture with
Snow White using real actors on film as
models for the anime celebrities who
must match their newly pencil people
some are genuinely interesting pieces of
trivia and others are so surprisingly
obvious you'll kick yourself for not
noticing than before so with this in
mind and these are screwing up the video
the vultures in the jungle book are the
beetles really animated tale the Wow so
many of us as kids
vultures went from being a bunch of what
the Beatles had the original plan was to
actually have the Beatles come in a
voice the birds themselves but
scheduling conflicts interfered in the
end though they still pair of startling
resemblance to the band number six Peter
Pan is Bobby Driscoll creating the name
Wendy no seriously and adding countless
words of the English language like dog
house no seriously
Peter Pan is another film Disney had
long to make and when at long last he
did his Peter became the definitive
version well tiny Peter is the
definitive version but it did dominate
the design of the character to this day
however really on the real-life Bobby
Driscoll the child star at the time very
young therefore saw that he was
immortalized in animated form as the boy
who never grew up Oh Ariel is Alyssa
Milano Arab is pretty much the modern
teenager
well not understanding his viewpoint at
all like she came across with real
personality I think even more impressive
I have fishy lower ha
to give her that defining what she
animates his turn to it yeah but then 16
year old was one of the main characters
in a sitcom who's the boss and it was
that role that caught the animators eye
she was really I know she went after
some lines we have the real life right
not least because of its retellings in
new doesn't change a lot of the key
elements though removing much of the
tragedy in putting a heavy focus on her
relationship with John Smith to cast a
Native American with sensitivity the
only real option is to cast the Native
American so Irene Bedard is one actress
who Laura how she's a beautiful and
crafty Pocahontas animators people I
don't also voiced the Native American
but that involvement came from her being
the characters model first number three
Ursula is drag queen defying those were
mermaids first let her speak bad and
heralded in an age of Disney villain who
were as visually interesting as they
were character wise to accompany this
idea of a larger-than-life personality
the animators based her appearance on
the Dratch oh gosh century by People
magazine that's issues we ought oh wow
mistakable look big made a heavy major
at queen evolving chin up all translated
across whoa new IDs
dime so never actually got to see his
most enduring tribute number to Sherri
stoner is to Disney Princesses we
cherish never listen Milano's look was
worked into ariel but both her and
originally developed on the same person
i'm stoner was actually in a way at
disney working as a producer and writer
on summer she's fruiting shows i find a
lot of people attractive Ariel
hair away from her face as with Vedad in
Pocahontas stone also provided the
animation model a role that she actually
really liked legit like a princess
number one natural based on me rough rat
and street rat the story goes that the
original design just looked a bit too
young so was digit in favor of a more
mature maverick inspired one once you
see there's always swing by what come
for more news like this every day as
always I've been Jules you've been
awesome must be TC thanks what culture
Wow fascinating piece of information we
got here in this video we do not agree
lisa bellick helic yes I would agree Wow
The Beatles The Beatles in the jungle
book I feel like everyone wants to
include the Beatles at some point yeah
and those vultures I don't get why the
vultures were so ugly though yeah they
don't resemble the Beatles to me
otherwise I mean I would have noticed
that their personalities I guess maybe
but I love the Beatle mr. Farrow Beatles
song I have so many name one I want to
hold your hand oh come on
too cliche come on I knew you were gonna
do that come on come on come on of
course when you asked me what do you
sing to your love what are your
favorites oh I want to hold your hand
Peter Pan is Bobby Driscoll I thought
Peter Pan was based on Conan O'Brien why
cuz of the red hair he looks Irish to
make pan Irish she's green clearly pan
isn't oh how could I miss that I don't
know why he doesn't sound like person
Joan my name's Peter Pan
he should have sounded like that that's
a fault on Disney yeah racist Disney did
not want to honor the Irish because
they're racists okay but that was really
what they said about Bobby turns cold
dying yeah I didn't know that that's why
they had the never growing up you
remember that in the video you know I
have a really short attention span just
do that okay oh yeah because the boy
died that's really sad
well now he's immortalized as Peter Pan
that's cool we all could get a Peter Pan
when we die you know well I have an
Aladdin oh that's right yeah you haven't
done I can show you the world you
haven't died though I'm dead on the
inside so no I think ariel is way hotter
than Alyssa Milano
I had to date Wow a fictional cartoon I
find a lot of people attractive and you
don't find her Alyssa Milano is very
attractive but if I were to be a guy at
a bar let's say I'm at like a pub and
then I see Alyssa Milano
she's strikingly beautiful but then I
see a mermaid first off what the hell's
a mermaid doing a land exactly secondly
that mermaid is way hotter than
Elizabeth I crack myself up people my
name's Greg Allen Pocahontas is based on
really loses Native American chick
Irene batad you know she looks like
Filipino I feel like that's why I'm
drawn okay because I'm half Filipino
okay
I mentioned this like every other day to
someone right and I already knew you
were yeah I just thought I should remind
you okay white woman she's racist over
here I don't know how but okay yeah you
agreed to come back I said I would make
things very uncomfortable no you didn't
well you would be comfortable if I
warned you I mean it's kind of sad that
he couldn't base her off the real
Pocahontas because if you look at the
photos the real Pocahontas she doesn't
look like the hottest thing in the world
but you need like these Disney
Princesses to be really cool yeah that's
Pocahontas
the original yeah that's a photo she's
so pretty the camera cut and I
completely defended Pocahontas the
Pocahontas movie is probably the most
insulting movie to its history actually
because it's so inaccurate and painted
in such a different light and that's a
whole other video but Ursula I don't
know who this drag queen girl is however
their makeups the same they look super
similar yeah I don't know how the drag
queen community feels about making the
evil character a drag queen yeah I don't
know either I don't even know if they
know that but if they did know that yeah
I don't know how they feel I don't know
I don't know I always thought I'd be a
great drag queen right yeah thanks oh
thank you I'm a supportive friends oh
you're not racist
no I don't know why you said you were
you did hmm improv Oh Aladdin and Tom
Cruise they do look so alike I never put
that together actually no they don't you
know you don't think they look alike
Aladdin the Tom Cruise yeah you don't
see it I know whoa you're oh I got put
that on camera
what on camera that was nice welcome
busy go to my page everyone go to my
youtube channel
oh just taking a photo this and then
insertive you coulda so this right here
oh god II can't see it was so white what
is going on this right here is the first
drawing of Aladdin I used to work at a
doctor's office you do this no
I didn't mean you mainly created it I
thought you drew it no no that's what
I'm asking no I can't even draw a circle
this picture I used to work at a
doctor's office and one of the patients
was the one of the main Disney artists
for a lot of the big Disney films and I
told him I loved a lot of his films so
what he did was he took a copy of the
first drawing he ever made of Aladdin
this is the very first drawing he ever
did and then signed it for me
it says to Greg yeah let's read it this
is one of the original model sheets we
use in the movie of Aladdin which was
mine character as you know he doesn't
know how to spell but he can draw yeah
may all your why oh you apostrophe re to
grammatically dreams come true as Walt
Disney once stated from the last of the
old Disney animators Andrew Ramos March
27 2012 that's awesome though yeah it's
really cool and like the sentimental guy
I am right I penned it instead of
framing it right he did and I thought
never frame it again it was never framed
I know don't okay guy feel good
ah guys Lisa mhealthy back in town and
she is better than ever I don't know how
yet because we haven't caught up
you can subscribe to the reel rejects
subscribe to what culture while you're
at it and more importantly go to Lisa's
channel what did you want to see this
face his personality and her own video
without this good-looking guy here I'm
just a distraction when you could just
be staring at this